Hello everybody my name is markiplier and welcome to a game called Constellation
Now this game is different than anything. I've ever seen before and I mean that quite literally because all you do is
type things, like: dog
or cat
or cow
Traffic cone
guitar
Skull
skeleton
man
woman
women
ooo
Men
cows
cones
Well hi
Okay, so I don't know if there's an objective to this game but
I've only I only just did a few things and apparently there's tons and tons of commands in this game
And I have no idea what they are so I'm gonna find out there we go uh, butt nope
sexy
boobs, nope
God dammit, a man can dream
ummm
happy
w-what?
what
Oh, it just saturated everything alright, okay, s-stuff
ooo, ah
duck, ooo
Ducks ducks ducks ducks ducks. Nope ducks ducks ducks
ducks ducks ducks ducks ducks ducks
ducks
ducks, di-- hehe
That ain't ducks nope Ducks
sun ooh
suns
many suns
lots of suns
ahhh
hundred suns Ooo
100 suns... son
ahh
star?
ohh wahaha
haha, haa
No oh I goofed it goofed it ok wait uh?
star
Ok alright universe
Galaxy
Whoa what the hell
whaaat the hell hehe
Whoa
That's awesome. That's so cool
so uh
That's a thing
What the hell?
cc-cell
Molecule, atom
what the f-
hoo hoo (high pitched) WHAT
I MADE THEM
ORBIT
(even higher) ORBIT!
(normal pitch) wow, okay, um, yeah, yeah about that
atom
(softly) atom
Okay cows
hehehehe
I got planet-sized cows in the galaxy
dogs
cats
All right, cool. All right. Everything is right in the universe when giant cat dog and cows orbit the galaxy
I think we all know this a safe place all right
Clear oh
Good good. Good. Good. Good. Good,
ooooooo
Beach whoa, oh whoa
cows
Cows are hehe cows on the beach. Okay. I got cows on the beach my dream has come true happy oh
ahhh
I can't see shit
phone
Phones, normal, oh whoa what the hell?
That's weird, forest
ha-owww
lake
oooo
sky
huh? that's sky? all right whatever you say sky
ummmm
All right, oh it changes the sky oh
God, no devil
wuh oh, WUH oh
Well, I'm in hell okay wait I know that skybox
Wait a minute isn't that the skybox from the from doom that is legitimately isn't that? am I crazy? (yes)
That's that looks like it's from doom. I might be crazy doom. Oh, oh
No now then now that
that is the skybox from doom I
Didn't know that game whoo. I got a score what?
Blows
Okay YouTube nope theater ah
Please dummy ah there we have it, Internet. Oh ah
3d it's dark applier everybody run away, okay?
Well, I just typed life okay, all right durian fruits oh
That's that's a thing of beauty oh, that is oh that is pretty
Okay, wait
There's something that's missing here cows
Okay well
Alrighty then
Oh
Okay see ya, okay. Bye oh
All right well there you have it okay, there's gotta be more words that I can come up with right, okay? Ah
Potato tomato
Aardvark
elephant
tree
No. phone, camera
Oh, it's a filter uh
aaaah Instagram
Constellation ooh oh I already got that Oh, Oh light
Make this cow really bright
That's a break-in happy almost there
There we go nice, okay?
What was
Jeff okay, what is matrix do oh, it arranges them in a matrix. Oh, can I go?
Oh
Now this this is the HD cow action I was looking for oh, that's nice. Oh, that's nice. We need one more cow
To do more okay each
Steam engine ah Steve Jobs lady no
Newgrounds
oil Graham, Dix once ass
Shit OOP whoopee ah I'm proud sad oh
Happy what else we got
Marsh oh is that a marsh so really a mark odds of marsh I can tell by the one Marsh
Whoa oh
Whoa
Cool beneath
Where oh well what oh all right, okay, okay?
Okay, ah
No, I don't like that okay, that's not good
Utah what?
What what is that the darker black mug teapot I'm in, Utah
Barely, what the hell was he Utah why is you -? Why'd you talk above our hurricane?
What doesn't make any sense?
okey-dokey then
Our glasses okay sky tubes good all tubes. Ah
Oh god oh god
Penguins all penguins and normal
Why Utah when you've a higher
Taxes now for now yay, Oh
Lahoma the VAD, Arizona
Lovely Canada, you're okay, oh
I still don't get this that doesn't make any sense
Seppia explode
Donut cinema
Vr. God, I'm like cross my eyes on this one wait and thrown out into 3d
It works oh my god, it works, I can't believe it works. Holy shit that works. What the fuck
Hey, it works. It works. If you cross your eyes it works
haha, Luz
Beach cow 3d
VR baby, oh, that's a nice cow it's coming right at me. Oh it's like I can touch it oh
Jeez, what else we got?
palm trees
Wool ah ooh. Why are they so big?
Offices oh
Ah it ruined it. What did I do I goddamn it okay office nope?
What turtle
Whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa-whoa
Okay
Vr3 be
Nice okay, so that's
Constellation I'm I'm willing to bet that there's tons more
Commands in here and you can get them by randomly generating a my guess, but I bet there's some hidden ones in here
So I'll leave a link to this game in the description below. It's really fun
It's just a very simple very different game, but it is fun
So let me know if you guys find any cool and interesting secret things in there because again
I'm willing to bet that they're hiding a ton, so thank you everybody so much for watching